what's going on reject nation we are
going to watch today spider-man no way
home behind the scenes featurette and
some new posters to look at too before
we go into that i want to give a special
thank you to today's sponsor a sponsor
that we have been wanting to work with
for the longest time and that is display
tell them about display guys display
makes these durable metal art prints
that are super easy to install display
and swap out they've got more than a
million designs in their store including
original art as well as some of our
favorite ips like marvel star wars dc
and so much more than that and not only
are the designs great we'll make them
especially awesome coming from a guy
who's had to put pins and a lot of
favorite posters of his or just use that
whole little scotch tape thing where you
double-sided you don't need any power
tools to install them thanks to
displate's magnet base mounting system
which takes only about 20 seconds to
install we just hung this awesome
spider-man design and i cannot wait to
continue growing our collection and now
is a great time to start your own
collection because display ships to over
56 countries and only about four to five
business days so hit our special link in
the description box to save yourself 23
on your first one or two displays or 27
when you grab three or more by
supporting them you're supporting the
channel and there's a support this is so
cyclical so do it now let's watch this
video
we're going to lift you up on a cherry
picker and you're going to jump off
now
it's just so funny
yeah yeah dude 20 minutes
[Music]
oh they're gonna be great
i gotta find the easter eggs for you
that's crazy
they look like they really mess around a
lot
god
i want it history it's great to see that
footage in high def over here man give
it to me wow that's crazy you know i
don't really watch behind the scenes on
blu-rays for some reason i think it's
because like many many years ago when
christian bale was doing behind the
scenes for batman begins he was like i
feel like some of that ruins the
mystique and the magic of movie making
and i'm like you know what christian
bale you're right and then i just avoid
it even though i watch it whenever they
go up on youtube
but i feel like i'm going to be
absorbing a lot of this maybe we can
react to some of it here on the channel
man i mean to see all this historical
stuff but i heard there's some new
posters that were released that's what
was going trending on twitter so i
wanted to take a look at those really
fast before we talk a little bit more
about this all you gotta do is go to
twitter and find that hashtag
no way yes
that's not a photoshop here we go again
it looks like a photoshop but i'm gonna
just say it's real
my lesson okay yeah according to variety
they actually did this for real for the
pro bow oh that's cool they they really
that is like 100 accurate almost it's a
little it's a little more chillax
helen's doing two nah that's not a
hundred percent not a hundred percent
but still looks pretty great is there
anything else
okay looks like we got some leak photos
here
yeah they're not high quality man it is
nuts we're actually gonna get promo
posters of just the three of them like
they're actual faces on there that you
could purchase
like being in a time capsule where all
of a sudden like some alternate universe
advertising is about to drop now that
yeah the cat's out of the bag oh wow we
got to get these framed or something
like that display get on it would you
people just coat every wall with one
spider-man each and then the fourth wall
all three this is so cool because like
when you're looking at the footage for
for what they did here to know that
they're capturing all that and that's
like a lot of the stuff that i feel like
a lot of us really want to eat up you
know when you think about the kind of
year maybe two years that we were all
going through wanting to just see any
little snippet we could spiderman no way
home now to be getting that really
fulfilled with the magic and the journey
behind it and a lot of that real behind
the scenes interaction of what it was
like on set because we've got all these
interviews with these guys where you get
all these stories with them and yet we
don't have any of the footage of them
just hanging out so we're gonna watch
those stories come to life and now on
that behind the scenes it looks like
we're going to be getting actual behind
the scenes footage of them coming to
life and some real quality interviews
with andrew garfield and toby mcguire
included in there i've never been so
hyped for a behind-the-scenes footage
thing ever to be unveiled
for a blu-ray before because of the
amount of secrecy surrounding this and
now the secrets are all going to be
coming out of the bag in more ways than
we ever realized you know well it makes
me wonder now too because you know i
mean these industries thrive on
re-releasability and content being
uncovered over the years and this seems
like a prime opportunity to release like
the most ultimate compendium of yeah
like behind the scenes footage
production notes all that stuff and they
said in the ad 20 minutes of the extra
other two spider-man like what what else
made it from the cutting room floor to
the blu-ray and and what else maybe from
like rewrites and stuff like that might
be included because you know i mean it
seems like this movie especially was
rewritten and tweaked all throughout the
process it's one of those things where
yeah it'll be super fun and super
immediately nostalgic to revisit all
those moments and see behind the curtain
but also yeah what did we miss and what
other potential flavors are there coming
from these guys it does feel like one of
the few historical moments of a home
video release where everyone's gonna be
paying attention and everyone's gonna be
scouring all the different features and
stuff like that and really trying to
figure out yeah how did they bring this
all together what's the story behind it
and it's funny i was talking to a friend
of mine last night who makes features
for blu-rays and stuff like that part of
what he you know approaches it with and
was talking about was the human element
getting all the people together to share
the stories and i feel like that's
what's going to be the most exciting
about this is everybody getting to
behold just what it's like it's already
been dazzling people in these interviews
that you know toby maguire and andrew
garfield have finally been able to do it
i feel like that is only going to
increase tenfold seeing the environment
on set and getting everybody's yeah
story and enthusiasm behind it because
it does seem like one of the biggest
passion projects ever made and also this
is a side note here i've always liked
zendaya so she was a fine mj within the
past two weeks i have seen all of
euphoria i just started from episode one
and i couldn't stop it and i am all
caught up and i don't know what this
mysterious tom holland cameo is that
people said they think they spotted him
but i'm like i'd i'd look for it i
couldn't find it but the fact that i was
seeing like someone zendaya back there
now too i'm actually really excited to
see more footage of her because
obviously she could act i didn't know
how well she could have like she is
phenomenal in that show beyond
phenomenal so i'm like man you got to
give her more screw time in the next
spider-man movie especially knowing just
how much more fame she's gathered just
from that show alone and so to see her
here and then i think those rumors about
tom holland and her going to house
together were false according to tom
holland i saw some little thumbnail
about him saying it'll be on the
demonstration it'll be on the bed and
then purchasing their home yeah going
through escrow
it's going to be really informative if
you're looking to buy a home you should
really pick up the spiderman
all right guys well are you gonna buy
spider-man no way home leave your
thoughts down below hopefully we can get
away with reacting to some of this we've
done a lot of blocks lately already
things so that it'll be it'd be cool if
you get some of this up guys subscribe
leave a like thank you again to display
for sponsoring this video once you've
got some great posters i got we've got a
few more to hang as well we'll catch you
guys soon
you